(paper airplane whooshing)
(graphic booming)
(upbeat electronic music)
- Through all these experiences
that you've had in the
past couple of years,
is there something that sticks out to you
that's been a learning
moment or a growing moment?
Whether it's an event or
whether it's just this thought
that passed your mind
that's really stuck out
to you as something formative
and directing you to
where you're going now?
- The two super-formative ones for me
happened when I was 20-ish.
One was I was in Paris
and I was a tourist,
and I'm sitting outside
the Notre Dame cathedral
and I have my map, I'm
trying to figure out
where I'm going next and by myself,
and this French girl comes up to me
and asks me for directions.
And I'm thinking, "Why is a French girl
asking me for directions?"
Like, it doesn't really, right?
Like, "Hmm, I should ask
this girl out, I got to,
let's see what she's doing
tonight and take her to coffee,
something like that, right?
And I chicken out, right?
I chicken out, I'm worried about my French
not being good enough or whatever reason.
So she walks away and I'm pissed
that I didn't take my shot,
not that it would've been amazing
but not knowing is worse
than the rejection.
And so I tried to take her picture
from across the river
as she was walking by
and she actually kind of walked
behind the stalls so I didn't get her,
but as soon as I got home
I put that on my wall.
I put that picture on
my wall as a reminder
to the next time I'm
afraid, I just got to do it.
I just got to say yes and figure it out
because not knowing is
worse than getting a no.
Like, that short term no
is okay compared to a
lifetime of not knowing.
And so I looked at that
everyday and I didn't actually
tell the story to my friends
and people who came over
because, again, I was
embarrassed and ashamed,
they just see this beautiful
French riverside picture.
But to me it's like,
"I missed my shot man!
(interviewers laughing)
Next time I'm not going to miss my shot."
You're like Eminem, you got one shot,
one opportunity, right?
- Yeah, I know, I know.
- To seize everything
you ever wanted, right?
You going to seize it or not?
- Got you.
- And so that saved me
because I said I wanted
to be a banker and my yearbook
said I'm going to be a banker,
I had that opportunity when
I'm making $300 a month
in my company and just sucking, right?
Like, not making anything.
And I get these opportunities to work
at Merrill Lynch and McKinsey consulting,
$80-100,000 starting salary,
flying me to New York,
putting me up in the Waldorf Astoria.
The whole deal, wine and
dine, what I thought I wanted,
the jobs that my friends weren't getting.
Like, what do I do?
Do I take this crappy company
that's not going anywhere
or do I take this dream
job that I always wanted?
And I remembered the picture
and what am I going to regret?
And I would regret not trying the company.
I knew that in a year,
I could get another job.
It may not be that job,
but it could be a similar job,
- Absolutely.
- but I wouldn't know if I would
get this company opportunity again.
So I had to go for it and be like,
"I'm okay with it without
working, but I need to know
because I don't want to
live the rest of my life
not knowing that, you know what,
if I gave it a little
bit more on that thing
then maybe it would've worked out."
And so that failure in
Paris with that girl
and putting that picture up on the wall
to remind myself with my failure,
that gave me the spark
to then better myself
the next time and just be okay.
And so that's what all
my decisions are through,
always trying to minimize regret.
Like, what am I not going to regret?
And the fear of regret
can help you push through
the short-term fear of whatever decision
that you need to make short-term.
And then the other formative lesson
was around that same time, coming back,
just figuring out how to
make my business grow.
And I told my business partner I quit
and it was like the worst day of my life.
I realized that I'm not
the first guy that tried
to sell software before
and by modeling success,
like somebody else has
already figured this out,
I don't have to come up
with all the ideas my self.
And I looked at how Bill
Gates started Microsoft.
Zero to one, like not how he
makes an extra million now,
but zero to one, how do you do
that? That's what I want to do.
And I found this story and I researched it
and I was making $300 a month
and within two months or so
I made my first deal that was
13 and a half thousand dollars
and that doesn't sound like
a lot of bank but, dude,
for me that was sick!
- Trust me we know.
- That was the deal, man!
- Absolutely.
- 13 and a half K, what? That's crazy!
Like this could actually work.
(interviewers laughing)
And more important than that,
I had a model I could repeat,
- Yeah, absolutely.
- so it's not just a one time deal,
I could sell it again and again and again.
And so that idea of, so the first one,
living with no regrets,
trying as much as possible.
And then two, whenever
I'm faced with a problem
I don't know what to do,
I try to model success.
Find someone who has already done it
and what can I learn from that?
Like, what am I doing
on my YouTube channel?
It's just modeling success,
it's just finding people
who've done great things,
and it's selfish for me.
I would do the YouTube channel
even if you guys didn't like it, for me.
It's my growth and my development.
I want to learn from
Kobe and all these guys
that we put up on the channel.
So I'm fortunate I get to
surround myself with that daily.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Thank you to the guys from VNR Media
for the awesome interview,
the full link is in the description below
if you want to check it out.
I'd love to know what did you think?
What are your thoughts?
Leave them in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
Finally, I want to give a quick
shout out to Kathie Moore.
Kathie, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
"Your One Word," it really
really really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying reading it.
So thanks again you guys for watching,
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(graphic booming)